nobody let us so much I've like ronal  mcdonald countrymen Trekkies mmm just  honestly like the most overpowering  flavor is pickle and then the rest is  just like a meat ball avalanche or like  meat avalanche in my mouth  I mean mccollins has got nostalgic  because I used to eat like core pounders  every day but it's like a quarter  pounder and a Big Mac out of baby was  really good it's like in McDonald's they  took me down fun fried tuna then and  then put them between McDonald's buns  it tastes vaguely like a lot of bread  but the thin sheet of plastic and like  the tiny aftertaste piece I'm so  embarrassed cause it's like it's really  good I think technically of Neapolitan  you can't really differentiate chocolate  or vanilla from subscribers I think  actually give me good french fries like  it's super awesome  you  it's really good  I'm very good it's just for Yannick  glory taking it